julian assange has been in jail for an
awfully long time he's now in jail in
the uk he was under
house arrest in a foreign embassy in
london
the us has now accused julian assange of
violating the espionage act
this has been going on for a long time
and it's just a dumb we are that it took
us a very long time years to ask the
obvious question what exactly did julian
assange do
wrong everyone all good people hate
julian assange what was his crime
exactly
was he hacking into other people's
computers was he stealing secrets from
the us government no
actually he was publishing things that
other people sent to him he was a
journalist he was an editor
that's literally true should you throw
editors in jail because they embarrass
you probably shouldn't not a good
precedent to set
even if you don't like the person's
politics you should be against that
a wide group of people are against it it
turns out we spoke recently to pamela
anderson who's trying to get a pardon
for assange watch this
he needs to do the right thing this is
one of those moments in history in his
lifetime too that he needs to make the
right decision
and so it's all up to you know president
trump but he would really
gain a huge following and a huge um
sigh of relief and gratefulness for so
many people on the planet spoke to roger
waters of pink floyd about it tonight
we're going to speak to julian assange's
father
and brother john shipton is his father
gabriel shipton is his brother
we're happy to have him on the show
tonight john gabriel thanks so much for
coming on
um first to you what
this is sincere question what did your
son do wrong
exactly what is his specific crime
well no specific crime at all tucker
he's just uh offended some people in uh
in certain sections of washington and
consequently has faced
12 years now of uh persecution and
harassment
and julian as you know is not
an american citizen yet he's been tried
under the 1917
espionage act to bring
julian to the united states under the
threat of 175 years
in jail nothing at all just to
embarrass a few people well for those of
us in the business of
embarrassing and offending people in
washington this is a bad precedent
which is i'll just be honest one of the
reasons i'm interested in this case
gabriel tell us the conditions that your
brother is in right now can you go see
him if you want
uh he's in belmar prison i visited him
in october
last year and since then he has had no
visits the prison the prison's in
total lockdown due to covert so he's had
no visitors from
any family or his lawyers
so you know he's in it's a maximum
security prison so it's got all the
most dangerous prisoners uh from around
the uk the most violent prisoners
and he's been there up uh on three years
now so
you know he won his he won his
extradition case uh
on january 4th and then the us
government appealed
and then a couple days later he was
refused bail so he's been in in
since january he's been sitting in
prison uh an
innocent man not able to see his family
or lawyers
um and we just don't know when when when
the appeal will happen
or or when this will end
and not just not simply innocent i mean
i don't even think the charges make any
sense against him in this country you
are constitutionally allowed i mean it's
the first part of our bill of rights
the first amendment you're allowed to
print things the government doesn't like
which is what he did
let me ask you gabriel is any american
elected official
i know there's activist types and cable
news hosts but any elected official
taking your side
on this well uh not since uh not since
um
biden's inaugurate inauguration not
since president biden's inauguration
20th of january we haven't had
there's been no it's been silent uh from
people in the congress in in senate
uh which is you know part of part of the
reason why we're
we're doing this tour is to encourage uh
encourage americans just
to stand up for their first first
amendment rights
um and speak and speak to their congress
people and tell them that
uh you know an espionage act uh
prosecution
go on i think we're having some audio
problems is it but let me finish your
sentence an
espionage act prosecution for printing
things that government is embarrassed to
see in print
is a scary precedent that's going to
come back and bite us in the butt
and we should we should not allow it
anyway john and gabriel i appreciate
you're taking time out of your tour to
come on tonight thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you